قالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
صدت ثماني محاولات روسيه للتقدم في مقاطعه
دنيا اسكو وقتلت فلوكان نحو 50 جنديا
روسيا واصابت 50 اخرين في استهداف مستودع
للذخيره
بازاله وثائقي قتل منتسب شركه فاجنر وبعدم
اجراء فحص جنائي لجثثهم
دنيا
واصابه ثلاثه اخرين في استهداف روسيا
للعديد من المدن والبلدات في المقاطعه
خلال الساعه الماضيه
ومن جهه قال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه الكسندر ستوبن ان الطيران
الاوكراني شن خلال الاربعاء اربعه ضربات
على مناطق تمركز لافراد والاسلحه والمعدات
ومنظومه تصوريخ مضاده للطائرات التابعه
للجيش الروسي
ات
نقل اكثر من 30 جنديا روسيا المصابا بجروح
خطيره للمستشفيات في منطقه
المحتله بدنياك
للعدو في منطقه
على 50 جنديا روسيا واصيب نحو 50 اخرين
وفي منطقه يزولوجيا فقد العدو نحو 15
جنديا وما يصل الى 20 جريحا على اي قواتنا
المسلحه